[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be diving into 40. that's
right 40 Harry Potter plot twists and
when I say plot twist so I am of course
referring to unexpected turns in the
story that surprised us moments that
challenge the assumptions and
expectations that have been built up
throughout the narrative and when it
comes to the Harry Potter story we have
to give credit where credit is due there
are a lot of twists and turns from
relatively mild to Major each of these
plot twists contributed to a compelling
story that left us full of intrigue and
suspense before we get started be sure
to comment some of your favorite plot
twists down below without further Ado
let's take a look at 40 of the moments
left us guessing in no particular order
Snape's religions kicking things off
with a bang who could forget the moment
when we discovered that Severus Snape
was actually one of the good guys all
along after years of what seem like
dubious reality on Snape's part it
turned out that his love for Lily Potter
and his guilt over her death motivated
him to protect Harry and work against
Voldemort this gathers the rat just when
we thought Ron's pet rat scampers was a
harmless side character we learned that
he's actually the animagus form of Peter
Pettigrew this shocking Revelation
changed the entire course of the story
as Peter crew was responsible for
betraying The Potters and framing Sirius
Black the scabbers spent a disturbing
amount of time with the trio as well as
the Weasley family better group brings
new meaning to the term rat the true
identity of Rab in the Half Blood Prince
we learn about the mysterious RAB who
stole one of Voldemort's horcrux's it's
not until the Deathly Hallows that we
find out RAB is regulus Arcturus black
sirius's younger brother who turned
against Voldemort and sacrificed himself
to protect the secrets
Dumbledore's tragic past Dumbledore
always seemed like a wise and
kind-hearted mental to Harry that was
capable of harming no one however it's
revealed later in the story that they
actually had a very dark past the
Revelation that Dumbledore was once
closed with the dark wizard Grindelwald
and shared his Ambitions for power added
a new depth to his character with some
Sinister undertones
the Elder one's true Master the epic
battle between Harry and Voldemort
reaches its climax when we learn that to
Harry is the true Master of the Elder
Wand this twist comes as a surprise
because unbeknownst to Voldemort Draco
Malfoy had disarmed Dumbledore making
him the once Master when Harry later
disarmed Draco he became the true owner
of the powerful wand
Harry is a horcrux one of the most
jaw-dropping revelations in the story is
that Harry himself is an unintentional
horcrux Voldemort accidentally
transferred a piece of his soul into
Harry when he tried to kill him as a
baby this explains the psychic
connection between them and adds a
heart-wrenching layer to Harry's final
sacrifice
Neville's importance to the prophecy
never Longbottom The Lovable Underdog
turns out to be just as important to the
prophecy as Harry the prophecy could
have referred to either Harry or Neville
but Voldemort's choice to Target Harry
sealed their Fates Neville's growth
throughout the series in his role in
destroying the final horcrux is a
testament to his true bravery
Snape is the Half-Blood Prince the
mysterious copy of advanced potion
making that helps Harry throughout his
sixth year at Hogwarts turns out to
belong to none other than Snape this
Revelation not only connects Snape to
Harry's success in potions but also adds
another Lair to his complex character
the truth about Ariana Dumbledore the
tragic story of Ariana Dumbledore
albus's younger sister is revealed in
the Deathly Hallows The Accidental
killing of Ariana by one of the three
young Wizards Albus amberforth or
Grindelwald during a duel adds a deep
sense of guilt and remorse to
Dumbledore's character it also helps to
explain Dumbledore's deviation towards a
path of good Tom Riddle's Diary in the
Chamber of Secrets we learned that the
diary Harry stumbled upon is no ordinary
diary it's actually a horcrux containing
a piece of Voldemort's Soul this
Revelation marks our first introduction
to the concept of horcruxes setting the
stage for Harry's quest to destroy them
all
serious Black's innocence in the
Prisoner of Azkaban we initially believe
that Sirius Black is a dangerous
murderous criminal who betrayed The
Potters however we later learn that he's
innocent and was framed by Peter
Pettigrew this twist transformed Sirius
from A demented wizard into a beloved
character and a father figure to Harry
the true nature of thestrals at first
vestral seemed like Eerie invisible
creatures that only Harry can see
however we later learned that they're
only visible to those who have witnessed
death this Revelation adds depth to
Harry's character as it highlights the
emotional burden he carries after Cedric
diggory's death
the try was a tournament Sinister
purpose the excitement of the trial was
a torment takes a dark turn and we
discover that it was manipulated by
Barty Grant Jr disguised as madai Moody
to transport Harry to Voldemort this
twist not only shocks us but also marks
a return of the dark lord to his full
strength
Ginny Weasley's role in opening the
Chamber of Secrets in the second book
Ginny Weasley is revealed to be the one
who opened the Chamber of Secrets under
the influence of Tom Riddle's Diary this
twist not only shocks us but also
highlights the Sinister power of the
horcrux and the vulnerability of young
witches and wizards
the true identity of patilda bagshot in
the Deathly Hallows Harry and Hermione
visit godrics Hollow hoping to find
information about the Duffy Hallows it's
here that they meet patilda Bank Shot
author of A History of Magic and
grindelwald's great aunt however it
later revealed that the old woman wasn't
patilda at all but instead nagini
Voldemort snake in Disguise Barty Crouch
Jr one of the most shocking twists in
the Goblet of Fire is the Revelation
that Barty Crouch Jr a devoted Death
Eater has been impersonating madai Moody
throughout the entire school year this
twist not only highlights the lengths
Voldemort's followers will go to but
also raises questions about trust and
identity I still think Barty crunch Jr
was one of the best defense against the
dark arts teachers the silver doe in the
Duffy Hallows a mysterious silver dough
Patronus the tarry to The Sword of
Gryffindor we later learned that the
Patronus belonged to Snape who was
secretly guiding and protecting Harry
throughout his Journey this moment adds
depth to Snape's character and further
emphasizes his love for Lily the tale of
the Three Brothers the story of the
Deathly Hallows As Told by xenophilius
Lovegood introduces us to the idea that
the Elder Wand Resurrection Stone and
invisibility cloak are actually all
connected Hermione's Time Turner in the
Prisoner of Azkaban Hermione's ability
to attend multiple classes
simultaneously baffles everyone
transcending even her own reputation as
an incredible student the big reveal of
her time Turner not only explains her
mysterious schedule but also plays a
crucial role in rescuing Sirius Black
and Buckbeak the true nature of the
Marauders map the Marauders map
initially just a cool magical artifact
turns out to be a creation of James
Potter Sirius Black Remus Lupine and
Peter Pettigrew this twist connects
Harry's father and his friends the map
and adds a layer of sentimental value to
it the vanishing cabinet in the Half
Blood Prince we learned that these
seemingly innocuous Vanishing cabinet in
the room of requirement is linked to its
twin in Borgen and Berks this connection
allowed Death Eaters to infiltrate
Hogwarts and ultimately led to
Dumbledore's death
and creature's tail in the Deathly
Hallows the creature the black family's
house elf reveals the story of regulus
black and his efforts to destroy a
horcrux this twist not only provides
crucial information for Harry's Quest
but also changes our perception of
creature who turns out to be fiercely
loyal to his late master
Hagrid's expulsion throughout the series
we know that Hagrid was expelled from
Hogwarts for a crime he didn't commit
that's why he didn't have a proper wand
in the Chamber of Secrets we learned
that it was actually Tom Riddle young
Voldemort who framed Hagrid for opening
the chamber and releasing the Basilisk
Dumbledore's injured hand Dumbledore's
blackened hand in the Half-Blood Prince
is a mystery until we learned that he
was injured while destroying marvolo
gaunts ring which was a horcrux this
twist underscores the danger of
horcruxes and foreshadows Dumbledore's
impending death
the deluminator's guidance in the
Deathly Hallows Ron uses the deluminator
a gift from Dumbledore to find Harry and
Hermione after he leaves them the
deluminator's ability to guide Ron back
to his friends is an unexpected twist
that speaks to Dumbledore's wisdom and
foresight Percy Weasley's return to the
family Percy Weasley's estrangement from
his family is a recurring subplot
throughout the series his return and
reconciliation with the Weasleys are in
the Battle of Hogwarts is a heartwarming
twist emphasizing the importance of
family and unity in the face of
adversity
the truth about Moaning Myrtle the ghost
Moaning Myrtle who haunts the girl's
bathroom is later revealed to be the
victim of the Basilisk in the Chamber of
Secrets this twist adds a tragic
backstory to her character and provides
crucial information for solving the
mystery of the chamber
the sword of gryffindor's power in the
Chamber of Secrets we later learned that
the Sword of Gryffindor has horcrux
destroying capabilities after absorbing
the Venom of the Basilisk this twist
sets the stage for the sword's vital
role in the series climax when Neville
uses it to kill nagini the fidelius
charm in the Prisoner of Azkaban we
learned that the fidelius charm was used
to protect the potters and that it was
actually Peter Pettigrew who acted as
their Secret Keeper this twist not only
explains how Voldemort found the Potters
but also further implicates Pettigrew in
their betrayal the peverell brothers in
the Deathly Hallows we learned that the
peveral brothers who are mentioned in
the tale of the three brothers were
actually the original owners of the
Deathly Hallows this twist connects the
Hallows to Harry's lineage as he is a
descendant of ignota's peverel the
youngest brother the taboo curse in
Harry Potter few are brave enough to
utter Voldemort's name in The Deathly
Hallows it's revealed that the Death
Eaters have placed a taboo on
Voldemort's name allowing them to track
anyone who speaks it this twist adds a
layer of danger to the story as the trio
must avoid saying his name to evade
capture Lupine the werewolf in the
Prisoner of Azkaban we eventually
learned that Remus Lupine is a werewolf
this request not only adds depth to his
character but also explains his
mysterious absences and his connection
to the Marauders Neville's parents in
the Order of the Phoenix we learned that
Neville's parents Alice and Frank
Longbottom were tortured into Insanity
by Bellatrix Lestrange and her fellow
Death Eaters this tragic twist adds a
heartbreaking backstory to Neville's
character and strengthens his resolve to
fight against the dark Forces
the golden snitch in the Deathly Hallows
we learned that the resurrection Stone
won the Deathly Hallows is actually
hidden inside the snitch The Dumbledore
bequeathed to Harry this twist not only
connects the Hallows to Harry's Journey
but also provides a poignant moment when
Harry uses the stone to see his loved
ones before facing Voldemort
Tom marvolo Riddle in the Chamber of
Secrets it's revealed that Tom Riddle
the mysterious character from The Diary
is actually a younger version of Lord
Voldemort it's also explained that the
appellation Lord Voldemort is derived
from an anagram of his name Tom marvolo
Riddle I Am Lord Voldemort
the mara Avera said in the Philosopher's
Stone Harry discovers the mirror of
erised when he first looks into the
mirror he becomes immediately excited
when he sees his family staring back at
him in this moment Harry believes that
seeing his parents once more is attained
attainable however is later revealed
that the mirror merely shows the viewer
the deepest desires of their heart
effectively eliminating any notion of
Harry being reunited with his family the
Bloody Baron in the Deathly Hallows we
discover that the Bloody Baron the ghost
of Southern house was actually once a
Suitor of Helena Ravenclaw eventually
killing her in a fit of rage before
taking his own life this twist adds a
tragic backstory to the bloody Baron's
character and deepens the history of
Hogwarts the three broomsticks owner in
the Half-Blood Prince Katie Bell is
viciously cursed and no one knows who's
responsible though we suspect it's Draco
we later discover that it was rosemata
the owner of the three broomsticks who
was responsible having been placed under
the imperious curse by Draco Malfoy
Harry surviving after Harry encounters
Voldemort in the Forbidden Forest he
shot dead by Voldemort's killing curse
what was initially unclear however is
that Voldemort's spell only killed the
piece of his soul inside of Harry and
not Harry himself this allows Harry to
return to the land of the living and
that's it for today if you enjoyed the
content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel which plot
twist did I miss comment below until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to live